what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the origin of voloom when I
did that video on Green Lanterns I kind
of jumped the gun but a tree that
doesn't really matter because with the
origin of bull soon it was a one shot it
was standalone I mean you could have
published that at the beginning of DC
rebirth and it would have been just as
fun as it is now that's the beauty of
one shots that's why I love one-shot
comic so much because they're not tied
to any existing continuity the only
exception to that that I could pick up
are one shots that are part of a story
arc so like Sinestro Corps war you know
superboy-prime or something like that by
the way guys I just finished reading
like I have a really finish I'm halfway
through the second part of Sinestro
Corps war let me play something if God
were right and Green Lantern right now
that's what would look like right now I
guess it's some of the best writing that
I've ever seen for Green Lantern in
general do so that stroke or war is
amazing it is so good oh man like I
would do all of Geoff Johns great
letters just to be able to do Sinestro
Corps war and I don't even read
blackest night or like brightest day
like dude I've heard those other those
stories are like stupid good like I'm so
like before charter fare boy but what
this does is this gives us Batman and
the Green Lantern's now this was cool
because it was only ever a matter of
time right I mean if there's any one
thing that DC had solidified over the
course of the publication history is
that Batman and Hal Jordan or oil and
vinegar they respect one another but
Batman doesn't really like it he doesn't
really like Green Lantern's at all and
you actually talk about that you know
with regards to or I guess I'll talk
about that with with Simon Baz later on
in this story but again Sam Humphreys
handling of Green Lantern's is nothing
short of spectacular I mean like Sam
Humphreys is amazing when he writes the
screen letter admit those because
remember Green Lantern's is for the new
guys those are the guys who never read
any of Jesse on screen Lantern Hal
Jordan integrate Lantern Corps that's
for the older the older readers that's
what the veteran readers of the Green
Lantern mythos for the new guys Green
Lantern's is for you now what this does
it kind of picks up from the tail end of
the previous story ugh we talked about
that you know that in the last story arc
we basically had Batman show up to sign
advantage Jessica Cruz would say I need
your help in Gotham City now what we end
up finding out is that what in Gotham
City fears reigning supreme more so than
it did before that's kind of the crazy
thing about this is because Simon Baz
offers us this really really cool
commentary where he's like I fought
against aliens I have I fought against
all kind
I fought the Red Lanterns you know I
fought some incredible tools out there
but nothing is more intimidating to me
than Gotham City that's what's so cool
about it because Batman is such an
intimidating force and I really like the
way the way that he's written here the
way that he's drawn here it captures
that intimidating aspect of Batman like
if you were just walking down the street
and Batman was just standing in an
alleyway in front of you and just kind
of looking at you I would just kind of
be like wha what and how I would just
kind of walk the other way because he's
or he's a really intimidating guy but
he's designed to be that way that's part
of his mythos and what we end up finding
out is the reason why Batman has brought
us I'm about to Jessica Cruz here is
because of the fact that in his mind
this all has roots with the Sinestro
Corps now with regards to them meeting
like Commissioner Gordon this was kind
of the cool thing because if sunbath
Jessica Cruz sitting down with with
Bruce Wayne and Commissioner Gordon
really for the first time and a
commissioner gordon's kind of introduces
like you know the really Batman's
liaison to the police force but the way
this is done is cool because it doesn't
seem like Batman views Commissioner
Gordon is like a subordinate like Gordon
does what I tell them to it's like you
know Gordon is the guy that in a lot of
ways I answer to you know Gordon is
really one of the only reasons really
the only reason why the police force
doesn't have it out for me in Gotham
City you know Commissioner Gordon's one
that keeps the the police force really
off of Batman's backside but what we end
up finding out is that within gonzo city
itself there's been a lot of civil
unrest riots and crimes and so like that
and all of its rooted in fear but none
of the people are connected they don't
know each other they never met each
other they don't have the same name they
don't live in the same place with the
exception of the city itself
there's nothing to to bring these people
together now assignment dad's initial
response as well as the Scarecrow which
is hilarious because Commissioner Gordon
looks at that and he's like this guy
think she forgot about we forgot about
the Scarecrow like who is this guy you
know and it's kind of funny because what
this does is this really reflects a lot
of Hal Jordan and sign and bat so that's
one of the cool things about is
character depending on how he's written
there are people out there who hate
Simon Baz I mean they just despise the
character of Simon Baz they're like
either it is Hal Jordan Jon Stewart or
Guy Gardner or or Kyle Rayner or it's no
one else like to them as those are the
only lanterns of each week just there
are others who look at some of that so
like I love the character of Simon bast
he comes from a difficult history he had
to deal with racism
things like that he reflects a lot of
real-world concepts a lot of people
really enjoyed his character but the way
he's written here he comes off very
house wouldn't like innocence he's like
well I know everything I've got total
control of the situation and that's
really kind of how reflexes so now of
course Batman's like that's ridiculous
you know there's no way that it's just
scarecrow this is too big for scarecrow
not only that he's like scarecrows you
know basically implements these toxins
by mediums that could be ingested you
know gas liquids solids different things
like that whatever it is is happening
now it doesn't impact people this often
this fast and if it did it would be a
massive gas dispersed throughout the
city of Gotham you know as opposed to no
physical indication that the Scarecrow
is even aware there now at this point
this is what we start to get into the
argument between Batman as Tom and bass
over the gun because that's been a huge
part of simon baños character and was
really ironic about this is batman
points out the flaw in that position
right off the bat I mean just
immediately he calls him out you know
the question is why do you have a gun
you don't need that gun you're not going
to use that gun here Simon Baz is like
the guns my backup plans if all else
fails I have the gun so I could save a
life Batman's like that stupid that's
absolutely ridiculous
Simon Badgers responsibles well of
course I know what I'm doing like I
don't question me I know what I'm doing
here Batman's answer to that is if you
did you wouldn't have a gun and that's
the coolest thing about this because
Batman's right he's got he's got a
Lantern ring literally the only thing
that he can't make is whatever his
imagined imagination cannot think of at
the time he can make anything he wants
to using a green lantern that's the
basis behind it the ring is limited only
by his imagination and of course the
ring as far as I'm aware will not let
him kill anybody except for the Sinestro
Corps I think it is maybe the Red
Lanterns I haven't gotten that far into
Jeff Jeff Jones Lantern run I know that
they I know that originally they
couldn't kill Sinestro Corps members so
they couldn't kill anybody
and then the rings were modified so they
can kill members of the special court
but the principle still remains that
Simon bass does not see himself as a
legit Green Lantern doesn't see himself
as a capable Green Lantern if he did he
wouldn't need a gun he could say any
problem that I could solve if it
involves physical force can be solved by
this Green Lantern ring now of course
this is really more just like
stubbornness more so than anything else
as well as Batman kind of trying to keep
a lock down on and control the situation
but this is what we also find out that
what's been circulating around the
internet
are these Batman's fear videos whereas
these videos talking about how Batman's
going to break into your home that man's
going to hurt
family that man's gonna do terrible
things to you Batman zero he's you're in
danger as long as Batman's alive they're
anti Batman propaganda designed to
target people at the same time
Jessica Cruz's ring begins going off and
when it does her ring tells her that
there is a there's a kind of fluctuation
in the emotional spectrum that the
Sinestro Corps energy is being
recognized as this one we basically
learned that whatever energy source it
is that's being dispersed or you know
that's causing all this is rooted in the
Sinestro Corps now of course the cool
thing is we also switch back to the
Batcave you know of course doing a
little more poking around and again this
is really kind of going towards the
intimidating nature of Batman you know
how dark and brooding is how slowly
serious he is 100% of the time the guy's
got virtually not a single shred of
emotion inside of his body and again
it's kind of funny because just your
crews the Simon badge just kind of start
making jokes you know Jessica Cruz like
when do we get a kick you know do we get
to have a lantern cave which in truth
that would actually be pretty cool if
like the lanterns got their own cave I
would be down with that like every
awesome like I would do I would love to
see that like a lantern cave Rob core
your assignment is to draw me a picture
of a lantern King I don't know if
anybody actually will but I think it'd
be kind of cool to see like a lantern in
the cave but but again at this point you
know Alfred is actually taken by the
videos the Batman is observing and
Alpher is kind of basically wrapped up
in this whole this whole fear influence
and begins attacking the Green Lantern's
now what this does is it gives us a
couple indications here the first is
that with Batman Jessica Cruz Simon Baz
you know Alfred all watching this video
Alfred is the only one who's impacted
which means that the video only impacts
certain people what we also do is we
basically have this scenario of Batman's
prediction coming to fruition when
Batman said to some of that you wielding
that gun is inevitably going to lead to
somebody getting hurt somebody's going
to get hurt or somebody's going to get
killed this comes to fruition and Alfred
when he takes the gun of spotted bat and
threatens to shoot him with it not only
that we also kind of switch over a bit
and we end up finding out now the reason
why this fear is spreading throughout a
spreading throughout Gotham City it's
sort of because of the fact that
scarecrow has basically found a way to
harness the power of the of the of the
Sinestro Corps ring he's harnessed the
power of this ring to use it for the
purpose of instilling fear now the great
bit about this writing from Sam
Humphries is that I believe this goes
back to scarecrow getting a Sinestro
Corps ring during black
tonight I think it was the way to
scarecrows character had existed for
years and years and years was that he
would instill fear in people but it was
really more of him just kind of being
screwed up you know being messed up
being a really terrible person but with
him getting a Sinestro Corps ring he was
part and parcel to fear it was a kind of
situation where all the fears that other
people felt could be manifested several
times over and in a way that was far
more potent than any fear toxin he could
ever create and what this did is it
basically made scarecrow and addict for
fear it made him really just an addict
in the extreme degree now again this
really touches back on the idea of him
getting this this Sinestro Corps ring
how it impacted him and what it's done
is created a sort of addictive nature
where he constantly needs fear he
constantly needs to either spread fear
or consume fear but it constantly has to
have his life immersed in fear and all
this really happened here is that after
the semester war ring you know because
the fear that there was coming through
that was so potent nothing else is ever
the same it's like if you said that me
had the greatest thank you with the
Stoney River in Louisville sat down he
said oh my god this is amazing
no restaurant you ever go to will ever
be the same because there's only seven
Stoney rivers and the whole of the
United States that's basically what's
happening here this was playing out in a
situation you guys need to go check out
Saudi River if you've never been there
it is amazing they're only open for five
hours or in the evenings but of course
Batman trying to take out Alfred is
really just kind of a continuation of
this idea this Simon basses gun is going
to get somebody killed not only that
after going through and analyzing you
know of course all these different
videos and stuff Batman does what he
does where he basically kind of a kind
of finds a pattern in a sense that it
really seemed to be totally disconnected
but the origin point for all these
different videos or at least when all
the videos are overlaid they point to
one single location to this one
particular you know legal spot which of
course is where the Scarecrow is hanging
out and now Sam Humphreys is just kind
of playing it fast and loose here he's
just like hey guys this is Batman I mean
it's Batman comics you know insert
reason here for why Batman is able to
find a bad guy
it's just how Batman is it's just how
his stories go it's not a bad thing it's
just kind of this intrinsic part of his
comic that we've just kind of learned to
adapt to and learn to accept because
this story has to end at some point and
so I might as well you know might as
well be done in a way that's tasteful
but also kind of a head official to the
Batman mythos but again there's still a
little bit of debating going on back and
forth between Batman if something dies
over the gun that he uses and what
Batman does is of course analyze these
humming bow is putting a destructive
skills to the test debase
looks rather bad your problem is not
that you believe that the ring is
inadequate your problem is that you
believe yourself to be inadequate you do
not have full and total willpower in
yourself now that's the kicker about
this we'll talk about this during the
green lantern secret origin but that's
the basis behind this when Hal Jordan
first became the Green Lantern
that's what Sinestro taught him that was
that was our introduction into the
nature of the Green Lantern race the
nature the Green Lantern rays require
complete and total adherence to
willpower I mean willpower is your
lifeblood if you fail to have any
measure willpower in yourself if your
willpower starts to erode your powers
will erode and it'll get to the point
where your ability to wield your ring
will be non-existent
that's what Simon Bosch has been
struggling with Simon Baz is basically
in a contradictory state it's the dog
chasing his tail some advance sits down
and says well the ring is not 100% I
mean the ring will fail me is somewhere
on line so in order to have my backup
plan I have a gun I had the gun so that
if the ring fails me I will be okay this
struggle with this is he can never
really give himself over to his ring in
his entirety because he doesn't trust it
well how can he even really know the
limits of his capabilities if he never
pushes himself to the limit if he
doesn't get rid of all of his crutches
and so again it creates kind of a cool
situation because you know with them
kind of descending into where it is that
scarecrow is located that this is where
Simon - really sort of has to delve into
himself well the reason why is because
you know the Scarecrow turns up the
juice on this machine you know he amped
it up to ten answers to eleven if you're
a huge fan of this spinal tap but he
acted up to Tim and the result is that
this fear fear of the Sun badge feeds on
or I guess as he experiences is amped up
all the same and all he sees in his mind
is a failure all you see is the struggle
that he and his family have been through
and that's the cool thing about this
because this was forcing Simon Baz to
face his fears and that's what Sam
Humphries has been doing in the green
lantern line of comics if you notice
that Jessica Cruise has to face her fear
the fact that she doesn't even think
that she's worthy of being a Green
Lantern she found herself worthy when
she was able to create a construct for
the first time Simon Baz despite all his
bravado despite all the promises that he
puts off but arrogance and the false
confidence he's really just a guy who
doesn't believe that he has what it
takes to be a real Green Lantern and so
because that's what it really forces him
to do is to kind of dig down inside and
cast his gun out it makes recite the
ability for me to overcome
my problem doesn't come through the gun
that I have the gun is there it comes
through my willpower it comes to my
ability to recognize how strong I am on
a fundamental level my ability to
overcome virtually any situation to face
my fears and so ultimately what happens
is he basically conjures vijaya
construct that destroys this Sinestro
Corps machine and the result of course
is that the is that scarecrow is
basically defeated but the cool thing
about this is that you know once
everything sort of begins to run down
scarecrows take any errors put under
arrest and so forth Batman speaks with
summoned bath separately you know for
some of that offers to hand his gun over
to Bruce Wayne to ensure Gordon takes
his stem you know Commissioner Gordon I
all actually hold on to that if you
don't mind but Batman says look I don't
really like Green Lantern's I don't
really like working with Green Lantern's
I never liked Hogg never liked how
Jordan you know he'd always spend this
time hot dogging in the air and he was
just you know he was a guy that I
couldn't really rely on because I didn't
really trust him he was a glory hound
but he says you are guys that I can work
with you're a guy who's still figuring
himself out you're a guy who's still
understanding what it means to become a
Green Lantern you're a guy who wants to
do good things now this is huge because
Batman basically says at some point I'm
going to call and you're going to answer
when that time comes that's what our
team's nature will be formed this is
huge Batman almost never extends out a
lifeline to anybody so it's one of those
crazy things where it's like if Batman
comes knocking on your doors as I need
your help you say okay and you follow
him and you helped him do whatever it is
that he needs to do you don't ask
questions
Simon Baz is being extended an
opportunity here that very few people
can say that they have and so because of
this what this is doing what same home
fries is doing it's basically setting
the stage for a bigger event later on
down the line now I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw how Jordan and the
Green Lantern Corps and we saw green
lanterns
coming to a head and some kind of a
crossover event maybe it will maybe it
won't I have no earthly clue but again
what this does this kind of it really
has Sam Humphreys kind of bringing us
back reminding us the whole thing about
volthoom who's in possession of you know
Rama's body and so on and so forth and
so what this does is actually lead into
the last Testament of the first Lantern
the origin story of those two but also
they kind of fun to go back and do the
story again because it's really just
kind of Simon baggage of Jessica Cruz so
let them find their place among Earth's
superheroes and understanding their
place within the realm of the superhero
mythos itself we go within the realm of
being a Green Lantern but if you guys
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rock court if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop
alike and yeah I will cut you all in it
please
[Music]